un
jour bonjour mes amis
ah non non non j'ai demandé et obtenu de
mon chef est un jour de congé pour aller
voir ma soeur et mon neveu victor1 un
beau garçon ou sa vie il a six ans
maintenant si c'est tout mon portrait
est justement julie j'aimerais dû
apporter un autre ces deux jolies boîtes
de bonbons la route chocolat sans des
chocolats oui et et vous françois
j'aimerais lui rapporter un joli ballon
d'accord où je tenais bon jouer un rôle
merci julie ça fait cinq ans
voilà je lis merci et un ballon rouge
bon il est très beau françois tonner
merci-facteur facteur c'est un peu
dommage que facile cette visite
justement aujourd'hui ah bon pourquoi
vous allez rater un les séances de
photographies de kazim il pose pour une
photographe de mode célèbre eau pour sûr
je lis ça ça m'étonnerait les six
acteurs casimir a été choisi pour servir
de modèle pour la nouvelle mode par une
photographe célèbre d'ailleurs elle doit
arriver d'un moment à l'autre c'est
possible savoir casimir ne sera pas là
et non je l'aï vu prendre le gâteau il
va justement crier que son oncle
archibald et sa tante adélaïde lui avait
écrit un mot chacun pour lui demander
d'arrivée de toute urgence
obinna l'anah bon ben moi je vais vous
laisser un peu basse et en attend alors
à demain et bonne journée un an ce qui
était à leur contrat
ah
ah bonjour comment me trouvez vous ainsi
est ainsi
bien je vais vous dire un secret casimir
devait poser pour des photos de mode
non mais vous vous rendez compte ce gros
balourd représentant l'île aux enfants
dans un journal non ça aurait été une
catastrophe
pour faire des photos de mode il faut
être deux noble race est
allongé astucieusement éloigné quasi mis
en lui envoyant une fausse lettre de son
oncle archibald lui demandant de venir
d'urgence et maintenant je m'apprête à
le remplacer
s'est pas fait à ne pas à dire je suis
vraiment tu es bon que kazim
bonjour vous avez bien fait de venir
vous aviez insisté on débute plus grands
mannequins vedettes du monde un
mannequin qu'est ce que c'est c'est une
personne qui pousse devant un
photographe pour montrer dans les
journaux il nous a bien la mode la
photographe doit rêver d'une minute à
l'autre
superbe pour tout vous dire la vina
photographes célèbres qui devait venir
avaient pris rendez vous avec casimir
mais j'ai tout de suite pensé qu'elle
préférait faire des photos de moi je
porte avec beaucoup d'élégance les
habits de soirée alors pour que casimir
ne soit pas mecs et je lui ai envoyé une
lettre lui disant qu'il devait partir
aussitôt roi sa tante adélaïde je trouve
que c'est vraiment une attention
délicate de ma part n'est ce pas
écoute françois il faut absolument
qu'ils fassent quelque chose le coach
dit je vais quand même pas aller
chercher casimir à la neige mais qu'est
ce que nous allons lui dire à cette
photographe elle va et curieuse c'est
sûr mais on savait quel genre de femme
seins on pourrait se préparer plus
facilement la recevoir bon ben moi je
peux te le dire j'en ai vu dans des
films ah bon et télévisions l'a sans
doute pareil elle portera certainement
une robe de couleur violent plein
bracelet et un collier perdre un grand
chapeau des lunettes de soleil plaindre
rouge à l'air derrière il y aura au
moins dix assistants du matériel
de très bien comme ça si on arrive
c'est gai salut
c'est donc c'est tout je peux m'asseoir
merci
bonjour mademoiselle je gère cette
affaire oui oui j'aime photographier la
star du coin casimir vous savez où il se
trouve
c'est c'est vous la photographe
non
puisqu'ils âgées des tâches
non excusez-moi mais nous n'imaginions
pas ainsi une photographe célèbre non on
vous croyait plus venez vous savez la
photo il ya un principe à garder les
vedettes elles sont ce côté là pareil et
puis les photographies sont de celui ci
oui eh bien vous savez nous avons une
mauvaise nouvelle pour vous oui casimir
a été appelé par sa tante d'urgence et
les parties tout à l'heure catastrophe
de catastrophe j'ai promis de rendre mes
photos demain mois bon bah va falloir
que je trouve quelqu'un au et
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est que ces lignes a b c
c'est monsieur du snob
bonjour moi zelda est devant vous le
mannequin le plus beau et le plus
célèbre de l'île aux enfants ok c'est
pas tout à fait comme ça que j'envisage
est mon modèle mais enfin peut-être que
vous pourrez faire à la ferme et je vous
propose
regardez
allô
oui oui bien sûr un instant oui oui
c'est pour vous
alors oui allô oui à vous êtes mannequin
oui mais j'écoute je suis à leonard chez
casimir entendu j'arrive tout fric ah
bah voilà
j'ai trouvé un deuxième modèle
allons-y
[Musique]
alors
voilà comme ça ça va
encore un petit peu voilà c'est bon là
c'est très sympa
mais vous savez ça me fait plaisir et
puis c'est très intéressant de voir
travailler
vous savez françois j'ai bien réfléchi
et je crois que mes deux modèles vont
contre très réussi ah bon vous est prévu
sur l'islam ne tombe boizel nous croient
que c'est facile à enfiler les habits
lââm et c'est vous qui avez décidé
d'être mannequin le second fnab et
voulait un art est ce que vous croyez
qu'ils font fines herbes et surtout
c'est juste ans yves absolument léonard
et ne triche pas
je suis trop impatient pour attendre et
dites moi quel genre de costume
monsieur du snob et leonard vont-ils
nous présenter à vous n'êtes pas au
courant mais non à bakhit fils et moi je
n'ai pas pris parce que ça c'est pour
une la nouvelle mode enfantine
bon allez non pas en place
cette option quoi
souriez
yoopa
voilà